we have seen so far an example of a
probability law on a discrete and finite
sample space as well as an example with
an infinite and continuous sample space
let us now look at an example involving
a discrete but infinite sample space we
carry out an experiment whose outcome is
an arbitrary positive integer as an
example of such an experiment suppose
that we keep tossing a coin and the
outcome is the number of tosses until we
observe heads for the first time the
first heads might appear in the first
toss or the second or the third and so
on so in this example any positive
integer is possible and so our sample
space is infinite
let us now specify a probability law a
probability law should determine the
probability of every event of every
subset of the sample space that is the
probability of every set of positive
integers but instead I will just tell
you the probability of events that
contained a single element I'm going to
tell you that there is probability 1
over 2 to the N that the outcome is
equal to n is this good enough is this
information enough to determine the
probability of any subset before we look
into that question let us first do a
quick sanity check to see whether these
numbers that were given look like
legitimate probabilities do they add to
1 let's do a quick check so the sum over
all the possible values of n of the
probabilities that we are given which is
an infinite sum from n go from starting
from 1 all the way up to infinity of 1
over 2 to the N is equal to the
following first we take out a factor of
1/2 from all these terms which reduces
the exponent from n to minus 1 or this
is the same as running the sum from
equal zero to infinity of 1/2 and to the
N and now we have a usual infinite
geometric series and we have a formula
for this the geometric series has a
value of 1 minus the number whose power
we're taking which is 1/2 and after we
do the arithmetic this turns out to be
equal to 1 so indeed it appears that we
have the basic elements of what it would
take to have a legitimate probability
law but now let us look into how we
might calculate the probability of some
general event for example the
probability that the outcome is even we
proceed as follows
the probability that the outcome is even
this is the probability of an infinite
set that consists of all the even
integers we can write this set as the
union of lots of little sets that
contain a single element each so it's
the set containing the number 2 the set
containing the number 4 the set
containing the number 6 and so on at
this point we notice that we are talking
about the probability of a union of sets
and these sets are disjoint because they
contain different elements so we can use
an additive 'ti property and say that
this is the probability of obtaining a 2
plus the probability of obtaining a 4
plus the probability of obtaining a 6
and so on if you're curious about doing
this calculation and actually obtaining
a numerical answer you would proceed as
follows you notice that this is 1 over 2
to the
second power plus one over two to the
fourth power plus one over two to the
sixth power and so on
now you factor out a factor of 1/4 and
what you're left is one plus one over
two to the second power which is 1/4
plus one over two to the fourth power
which is the same as 1/4 to the second
power and so on and now we have 1/4
times the infinite sum of a geometric
series which gives us 1 minus 1 over 1
minus 1/4 and after you do the algebra
you obtain a numerical answer which is
equal to 1/3 but leaving the details of
the calculation aside the more important
question I want to address is the
following is this calculation correct we
seem to have used an additive 'ti
property at this point but the additive
'ti properties that we have in our hands
at this point only talk about disjoint
unions of finitely many subsets our
initial axiom talked about a disjoint
union of two subsets and then later on
we established a similar property for a
disjoint union of finitely many subsets
but here we're talking about the union
of infinitely many subsets so this step
here is not really allowed by what we
have in our hands on the other hand we
would like our theory to allow this kind
of calculation the way out of this
dilemma is to introduce an additional
axiom that will indeed allow this kind
of calculation the action that we
introduce is the following if we have an
infinite
sequence of disjoint events as for
example in this picture we have our
sample space we have a first event a one
we have a second event a to the third
event a three and so we keep continuing
and we have an infinite sequence of such
events then the probability of the union
of these events of these infinitely many
events is the sum of their individual
probabilities the key word here is the
word sequence namely these events these
sets that we're dealing with can be
arranged so that we can talk about the
first event a 1 the second event a 2 the
third one a 3 and so on to appreciate
the issue that arises here and to see
why the word sequence is so important
let us consider the following
calculation our sample space is the unit
square and we consider a model where the
probability of a set is its area as in
the examples that we considered earlier
let us now look at the probability of
the overall sample space our sample
space is the unit square and the unit
square can be thought of as the union of
various sets that consist of single
points so it's the union of subsets with
one element each and it's a union taken
over all the points in the unit square
then we think about additivity we
observe that these subsets are disjoint
if we are considering different points
then we get disjoint single element sets
and then an addict tivity property would
tell us that the probability of this
union is the sum of the probabilities
the different single element subsets now
as we discussed before single element
subsets have zero probability so we have
a sum of lots of zeros and the sum of
zeros should be equal to zero
on the other hand by the probability
axioms the probability of the entire
sample space should be equal to one and
so we have established that one is equal
to zero this looks like a paradox is it
the cut is that there is nothing in the
axioms we have introduced so far of the
properties we have established that
could justify this step so this step
here is questionable you might argue
that the unit square is the union of
disjoint single element sets which is
the case that we have in additive 'ti
axioms
but the additivity axiom only applies
when we have a sequence of events and
this is not what we have here this is
not a union of a sequence of single
element sets in fact there is no way
that the elements of the unit square can
be arranged in a sequence the unit
square is said to be an uncountable set
this is a deep and fundamental
mathematical fact what it essentially
says is that there are two kinds of
infinite sets discrete ones or informal
terminology countable these are sets
whose elements can be arranged in a
sequence like the integers and also
uncountable sets such as the unit square
or the real line whose elements cannot
be arranged in a sequence if you're
curious you can find this the proof of
this important fact in the supplementary
materials that we are providing after
all this discussion you may now have
legitimate suspicions about the models
we have been looking at is area a
legitimate probability law does it even
satisfy
countable additivity this question takes
us into deep waters and has to do with a
deep subfield of mathematics called
measure theory fortunately it turns out
that all is well area is a legitimate
probability law it does indeed satisfy
the countable additivity axiom as long
as we only deal with nice subsets of the
unit square fortunately the subsets that
arise in whatever we do in this course
will be nice subsets that are not nice
are quite pathological and we will not
encounter them at this stage we are not
in a position to say anything more that
would be meaningful about these issues
because they are quite complicated and
mathematically deep we can only say that
there are some serious mathematical
subtleties but fortunately they can all
be overcome in a rigorous manner and for
the rest of this class you can just
forget about these subtle issues